[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I'd see you down there so
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
what are you doing home
brother
what are you doing home
I knocked on come Sony Larry he's just
sitting there
didn't do nothing
smoking
but he was smoking Siobhan how do you
smoke in your sleep like have you been
rowing
we haven't been around
I think we've been wrong
why wouldn't they ask the door to me
maybe he just doesn't like you no more
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
would I try him again
that's a bit bestie
after security
never says hello never [ __ ] says
hello
[Music]
get to five around
have you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
what the hell are you working after
[Music]
Wards he's called six paints more from
here what is my mother did yeah he was
he was nearly stays over the wife that's
the truth
[Laughter]
sit somewhere else
huh
but I have my point there Carl yes he's
playing there column from when he came
in in order he's playing before
okay I'll sit somewhere else so
are you Robin
I didn't think we were wrong
well you're around he's sitting outside
in his own like a watchful
look like we're rolling
I suppose I'd just go talk to him soon
see what all this is [ __ ] about that
would be the best thing
no I'm sitting here next year and if
you're going back inside I'm following
you inside and if you're going home I'm
following you there too
now
if I've done something to you just tell
me what I've done to you and if I've
said something to you maybe I said
something when I was drunk and I've
forgotten it but I don't think I said
something when I was drunk and I've
forgotten it but if I did then tell me
what it was and I'd say sorry for that
too Colin
told me hard I'd say sorry just stop
running away from me like some fool of a
Moody School choke
which you didn't say happen to me
you didn't do up to me well that's what
I was thinking like
I just don't like you no more
[Music]